hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is cameras never seen I have been
teasing this one for a while now
and today I am watching dread I kind of
feel like I'm on a Sylvester Stallone
kick after watching rocky also Rob
Schneider isn't it that's weird
I'm so ready for the predictions on this
one I wrote give me those original Judge
Dredd prediction hashtag camera's never
seen with a semester Stallone gift with
him going I am the law
all right y'all I am ready for this very
excited let's do it
[Music]
up it so cheesy weird cheesy like dark
vibes of the 80s but like Rob Schneider
was in it was just very odd that that
was odd and cheesy I was entertained in
the beginning they pull of Star Wars and
the words rise up from the bottom and
they tell you about like the third
millennium and how the laws have
collapsed and now there's the elite
force called the judges and they are the
law and it's so cheesy already and then
it says so let's just alone is in this
and like yes and then it's like Rob
Schneider is in this and I'm like derp
you first see Rob Schneider and he is
being transported from prison to his new
home which is in like a really janky
riot II part of town and he is making
these faces like looking around and he's
just he's so bad
open his mouth we're like why is your
mouth open right now I'm sorry friend
but no so you see the riots where'd Rob
Schneider live and the judges show up to
take down the riots and they show up all
these giant motorcycles it looks like
those motorcycles that grandpa's ride
they have three wheels it's like
tricycle motorcycle none of this is
equipment that the judges use or like
their outfits none of it looks practical
and everyday use I'm sure like in the
comic I'm sure it looks really cool like
drawn out it just doesn't look practical
at all like the Sylvester Stallone looks
like Michael Jackson in a lot of the
shot like you're like gold chain
like these huge shoulder pads and is all
gold and very bulky and they look like
Michael Jackson or Rihanna or something
I am the law drop your weapon I can't
speak normally ha oh so much has already
happened so the bad guy RICO escapes
from maximum-security prison in the most
dramatic way you like shoots this guy's
vocal cord box then like jumps off the
side of the thing everything exploding
there's so much drama none of it is
really earned yet like you don't even
really know what's happening shits it's
hilarious
Diane lang and Sylvester Stallone are
talking about clusters judge dreads only
friend that he's ever had
she's like what what happened and he's
like you want to know what happened I
judge to then you find out that Rico
used to be a judge and he was turned in
for being corrupt and he activates some
illegal giant robots because of course
he does
I will say those those illegal robots
are maybe the coolest part of the film
there's a lot of awesome concepts in
this movie that don't get fully realized
at all but um I think did and I really
enjoyed them so Dredd
shoots a reporter and I wrote down but I
suspect it wasn't really thread because
of course it's not really dragged and
the whole movie he did really really
just like cool calm and collected and
then he's going through trial for this
murder of the reporter and they finally
give the final verdict and they're like
he's guilty and he goes nuts he starts
screaming it's a lie but you can't
really hear anything I had subtitle on
thank goodness healing it's a lie
I know why I could do it I don't work
too long I am a ball mouse doesn't weird
like separating from space pain you know
he gets life in prison instead of being
killed because chief justice
decides to take the walk of honor or the
walk of the end of your days and it's to
call something specific but if he
decides to do that he gets one thing
that the whole city has to like abide by
and he's like alright I'm gonna take my
walk of shame of Justice here and you
have to let drugs live so real
cool idea to the scene where Chief
Justice is walking out to leave the city
limit it's awesome I want to see the new
Judge Dredd because like if they do it
well like I think it's pretty thick so
the plane taking Dredd to his life
sentence in prison is also taking Rob
Schneider that plane is compromised and
it's like an air bus plane doesn't got
an air boat either but whatever people
they're in it's being taken to the
prison I wrote shuttle taking Dredd to
jail with attack and only dread and derp
surprise so dread and derp are trying to
get back into the city limits so they
can take out Rico who's now taking over
the city and you find out that dread is
fake and Rico is fake and they are
brothers and this soap opera is just
very high budget then I realized for the
first time Rob Schneider's character's
name is Fergie its Fergie like Fergie
Fergalicious derp derp derp derp derp
derp derp derp Fergalicious definition
make the dreads go loca not worth it see
find out that rico is trying to bring
alive this entire army of clones they're
just like Rico and they're going to take
over the city for his evil purposes
which aren't ever really revealed either
he just evil in lumps control I guess
and they've got these clones and he's
like attacked with the clones and the
computers like oh they're only 60% blah
blah blah beep beep beep boop and he's
like it's okay just just release them
and it could have been so cool they came
up and they looked awesome and they
would like not fully done they looked
like they look like God Deadpool from
like from x-men origins and I could have
been like this really neat fight but
they didn't even where did they go
suckers they were like coming out and
then there's like they didn't even fight
it wasn't they didn't use them at all
and it was like the whole thing of the
whole movie was like you're these
creepy-crawlies clothes why
then I mean everything's reactive really
quickly like Ferdie does is one good
thing in the entire movie he like
deactivates the big war robot and then
Sylvester Stallone takes out Rico and
and then they're done was just the one
comes out he's like at my under arrest
and they're like no everything was
resolved while you guys were fighting
don't worry about it bye it was very
cheesy but I'll say it kept my attention
a lot more than like a good handful of
some other movies that I watched the
people like genuinely like I've heard
bad things about this film but I mean it
was so cheesy that it was entertaining
at least I'm not mad I watched it I am
now that they didn't go further with a
few things but the dialogue was
hilarious some of the practical effects
were really cool I loved Sylvester
Stallone I loved Diane lang and I hate
Rob Schneider so like eight out of ten
yell it happen I'm betting at least a
dozen instances of you holding your nose
and doing a Stallone impression of some
of his lines
I shouldn't hope think knows and does it
that would have helped not sure how to
do it the low depression the wall nope
that's not it I'm interested to discover
what your tolerance level for Rob
Schneider in this movie will be on a
scale of one to ten
I'll give it a derp and a half you will
confirm that Rob Schneider is a terrible
sidekick he is the worst sidekick of all
time out of any sidekick that's ever
been Rob Schneider is the stapler you
will want to cosplay a judge just to
show off your awesome as a giant
chin it's very like looks like yeah go
I'll slice you I knew you would say that
you're going to be annoyed when Diane
Lang isn't the center of the movie yes
also Armand Assante will have you swoon
with his Latin jump ah
he wasn't my cup of tea but I mean he's
fine too loans eyes will creep you out
yes in my notes somewhere I wrote and
then Sylvester Stallone dot with dot
contacts dot dot question you will find
Rob Schneider absolutely annoying like
we all do
yep how does like I get jobs like how
are there good actors out there who has
never worked in their life in and
there's Rob Schneider who gets put in
giant things in projects I just made me
kind of sad actually thank you for
watching and thank you so much for the
predictions if you would like to predict
things I tweet about it once a week
usually on my Twitter Tim Rael chambers
he might just watch dread next week
we're demolition man or doom or Garbage
Pail Kids I don't know what you guys
want to see let me know thank you for
watching I will see you all next I had
to law ow
[Music]
[Applause]